[Music]
while mainstream media focuses on
Trump's locker-room talk and Clinton's
emails there are actually a whole slew
of other interesting political stories
happening right now related to the
presidential election this election has
seen a massive shift in America's
political alignment on both the left and
the right on the Left we've seen a real
divide between the Bernie wing of the
Democrats in the Clinton camp Bernie's
message against Wall Street money in
politics and his chastising of the
political establishment has been
swallowed wholly by the political
Clinton machine while bernie is now
supporting Hillary it's pretty clear
that many of his supporters aren't
following his lead in either donations
or enthusiasm this division is one of
the reasons Hillary is still struggling
with young people and overall connecting
with new voters meanwhile on the right
we've seen the absolute fracturing of
the Republican Party as we know it
mainstream Republicans like Paul Ryan
John McCain and Jeb Bush are now on the
outside looking in as Trump has
aggressively gutted the party it's
pretty clear that if Trump wins in
November the old guard of the
Republicans will be out and his inside
circle of people like Rudy Giuliani
chris Christie and ben Carson will be in
while the list of Republicans not voting
for Trump continues to grow the
Republican base who voted during the
primaries is still with him and whether
the party is supporting Trump or not
those people are Trump's rise also
fractured the Republican Party
ideologically neo-cons are either in
hiding or defecting to Hillary while the
Christian conservatives are backing
Trump a candidate who is probably their
last choice when this election began
let's not forget this is a guy who
compared his own book to the Bible as
they say politics make strange
bedfellows for both the Democrats and
the Republicans 2016 will be looked back
on as a watershed year regardless of who
wins it's clear the parties are in flux
and they both desperately need new ideas
and new leaders the fact that we have a
69 year old Democrat running against a
70 year old Republican tells you all you
need to know
about the aging state of our two-party
system how is it that these two were the
best star system concern out while it's
easy to mock Millennials just imagine
how you would feel if this was the first
presidential election you ever really
paid attention to or had a chance to
vote in we've got the ultimate reality
star running against the ultimate
insider and while they may hate each
other they're also perfect for each
other by the time this thing is over
they'll have thrown out everything but
the kitchen sink but that'll only be
because they needed it to wash their
dirty hands one of the many issues which
seems to have been almost totally
shelved during this campaign is science
I guess in some ways science is the
obvious sacrificial lamb in an election
contest focusing so much on mudslinging
instead of discussing the actual issues
that affect our lives as we discussed
during my chat with transhumanist Zoltan
Istvan
two weeks ago there are so many huge
upcoming scientific breakthroughs coming
down the pike from stem cell research to
cloning to artificial intelligence that
we must talk about these issues now so
that we'll know how to deal with the
ramifications of them both good and bad
when they're right in front of us
scientific breakthroughs will continue
to happen whether we're prepared for
them or not
perhaps we can never be fully prepared
but we at least need leaders who believe
in the merits of science in the first
place my guest this week is theoretical
physicist Lawrence Krauss Krauss is the
foundation professor in the school of
Earth and space exploration and physics
department at Arizona State University
as well as the director of the origins
project at ASU which focuses on the
origins of humans and the universe
itself Krauss has been outspoken this
election related to politics and science
particularly the seeming lack of
knowledge in this department by Donald
Trump we're going to dive deep both into
science and politics as well as the many
places that the two intersect I figure
if a guy can spend his adult life trying
to figure out the mysteries of the
universe then maybe just maybe he can
figure out the mysteries of our current
political existential crisis
[Music]
joining me this week is an author a
theoretical physicist and a professor at
the school of Earth and space
exploration at Arizona State University
Lawrence Krauss walk with Rueben report
it's great to be here you are in the
middle of like 8,000 things and we're
gonna have to use some theoretical
physics to fit this in the time
space-time continuum plus or minus a
million yeah yeah plus or minus a
million all right well I'm very excited
to talk to you I think I publicly shamed
you into doing this several times every
reason really yeah well it's hard to
publicly shame me but you did try yeah
yeah he did yeah and and but I wanted to
do it it's just a matter of fitting in
and it's great that we can be here today
yeah all right so I'm very excited your
head to UCLA to do some more talks after
this now let's let's jump right into the
election okay because I have to yeah
well maybe we'll talk about science no
you know why not as a man of science
uh-huh how do you feel about just the
tenor of this and and not just the tenor
but as someone that cares about
empirical evidence yeah I care about
facts how do you feel about just the
state of what is going on right now it's
every every year I always wonder if it
could be worse because you know let's
face it politics and empirical evidence
don't go together very well as a rule
and know for a long time I've been
interested in trying to make sure public
policy is based on that and in a lot of
different ways in my writing and we we
actually created a group in 2008 called
science debate which we tried to get a
presidential debate on issues of science
and technology not to ask them the tenth
digit of pi but I mean if you the issues
that really matter
yeah that are going to affect the future
for people are not the issues that ever
talked about their energy the
environment security all of that depends
on on an understanding of Science and
Technology Policy and so it's always
been ignored and we and we've been
frustrated by but but I have to say that
this is this year of course with Donald
Trump takes the cake in so many ways you
see I wrote a piece in The New Yorker
which more or less called him the anti
science candidate if such you think it's
possible the only person I think on the
Republican slate that was more anti
science remarkably with Ben Carson right
let's just talk about Carson well yeah
yeah no I want because it yeah why not
because I'm such a fool how can be he's
an he's a neurosurgeon neurosurgeon
right how can
to be a neurosurgeon and against so many
of the things that a scientist has to
believe in well not just against
ignorant about them that that's what
amazed me it's it's it's it's one thing
to be I logic ideologically opposed but
he would talk about evolution away which
clear the clean lever didn't understand
evolution which is the basis of biology
besides calling the big bang hoax from
the devil and all I mean just well that
yeah yeah exactly you know that and the
fact we didn't land in the movement but
uh but uh so what it demonstrates is and
it's unfortunate but actually it's
relevant my mother wanted me to be a
doctor and and and she made the mistake
of sort of getting me interested in
science and and want to be a scientist
and then I discovered when I was in high
school the doctors weren't scientists I
apologize to all doctors they're not and
and he's a perfect example you to be to
be a good dot and that that's not to say
many doctors trying to keep up with
science obviously sure but to be a good
neurosurgeon requires eye hand
coordination and oh and an understanding
of what to what to do when you open up a
brain it's I will get in trouble for
saying this but it's a very
sophisticated kind of car mechanic and
so he clearly was very good at those
technical things but obviously uh you
don't obviously he not only did not know
much science but he he willfully and
this is the real problem with with
religion with someone like him he
decides what's right based on the
Scriptures and anything disagrees with
it must be wrong and that's that's the
real difference between religion and
science where in religion you know the
answers before you ask the questions and
in science we try and ask the questions
and find out the answers and they may
surprise us yeah and they may change
over the course of nolle may they often
do and their willingness to say you're
wrong or to change your mind is
profoundly important in science which
brings us back to Donald Trump but real
quick just to finish with Carson began
it's such an interesting example of this
I'm glad you made the distinction of
saying that he's a neurosurgeon non
scientists yet now fumble the twice it's
our because a neuroscientist has to
really have the scientific knowledge the
way you're describing the you know a
souped-up car guy car mechanic it's like
really he's doing he's doing
physical act he's repairing damage and
and he needs to know how to do that it
you know I again one does want to
generalize for all neurosurgeons based
on Ben Carson but it demonstrates that
there's a difference yeah and he and I'm
assuming he was good at what he did and
it wasn't all hype I'm willing to grant
him that but in everything else he says
he expressed more ignorance not just
antagonism but ignorant about
fundamental science than any other
candidate in the Republican Party which
says a lot because yeah because there
you know there it is unfortunately
become the anti science party of late
and it wasn't always that way their
public party has been a big support of
science over the years right now because
they insist on denying the existence of
climate change and many on the right
insist on denying the existence of
evolution or even the Big Bang and their
their attitudes towards homosexuality
they have necessity by ideology been
forced to confront the evidence of
science and ignore it or or disregard it
or or lie about it right so basically
they've staked out a position based on
non fact and then that sort of boxes
them in there are no real problem what
do you do when when you're wrong and you
can't afford to say wrong and the
problem actually the real problem with
politics is people are not willing to
say you know what we had this policy but
it was wrong we've changed our minds
because it and and I really the public
one of the reasons I want to have wanted
to insert more science into into public
policy is not not the knowledge of
science but the process of science which
is based on empirical evidence and
testing and and evolving your views and
if we really want to have sound public
policy we can't we can't just be willing
to say oh well someone was wrong once
and therefore you know we're not going
to listen to them stating you're that
we're wrong and explaining why is to me
raises you to a higher level it's a
beautiful thing it's a beautiful thing
in fact as a scientist often say as a
theoretical physicist I say the two
greatest states to be in our being wrong
or confused because that means that what
a lot more to learn yet there's a little
room there for for a lot of rooms I mean
I mean it's really learning is
a process of discovering errors and what
you were thinking and and I have often
I've said in fact my new book I said
somewhere that that science one of the
purposes of science is to to make people
uncomfortable
and and I don't mean that in a bad sense
but if we're always comfortable it means
we're never going outside our comfort
zone it means our myopic views are never
being questioned or confronted and
that's what living is all about that's
what mute music art literature are all
about I mean it's you know I'll bring in
happens to be today I'm excited because
Bob Dylan just won the Nobel Prize
you know but but you know people like
Bob don't force us to confront I
remember when I was young our views
about ways society worked and science
should be the same way and and good
politicians should be should be all
about that it's amazing to me when I've
been in in some other countries and and
and and confronting presidents or prime
ministers who actually I who actually
know something yeah
and then even I'm you know that's not to
say I mean Obama's of yeah anyway I
don't wanna yet what we will get mail no
matter what yeah we can you're gonna get
it I hate what wait to see what happens
on Twitter but uh but we can talk about
Obama claim but interestingly it sounds
like you're saying you don't necessarily
care if the if the president knows that
much about tides but you at least want
them to be intellectually curious enough
to to assign the right people
exactly it look the president can't be
an expert in everything yeah but the
president needs to know they're not if
the first thing is to know you're not an
expert in everything which Donald Trump
hasn't yet figured out right and
secondly to be intellectually curious
and thirdly to choose the right people
that's really what you want a president
to do is have good advisors is to know
enough to distinguish people who are
full of garbage I'll use that word and
and and and people you can trust
whose opinions you can trust because you
know that they're willing to be wrong
too and so I think that's really the
mark word president and uh in in in the
current climate you obviously can't be
an expert in anything and an amazing me
when we talk about you know having
debate on science they say well the
president should be a scientist but you
know you know we have a debate on
national security but with the president
doesn't have to be a military expert
surrounded himself or herself with with
reasonable people who know what's going
on or on diplomacy so is the
intellectual curiosity part of it is
that the part that about Trump gets you
the most well its intellectual curiosity
and skepticism and skepticism is a key
part of science be asking yourself is
this evidence reasonable and why should
I believe that yeah but the thing that
it's hard to know what an Trump is such
an anomaly but the fact that when he
says you know who do you take advice
from he says for myself because I'm you
know I know that or Matt when when
someone says that no matter what the
running for whether it's president or or
or head of a school board or whatever
you should worry about that and and so I
think it's that and his incredible anger
and vindictiveness and you know people
have called him a bully but you know I
did I did a dialog with it with a
Hollywood friend of mine named Johnny
Depp and he and he point out that wasn't
who he actually he actually played
Donald Trump in it you should watch it
on Netflix see a great show where he he
looks just like him it's great but he
said that Don Trump isn't a bully he's a
brat and that that defines the man to me
he's not a bully so much it's just a
spoiled brat who if he's losing finds a
reason to blame other people it again
he's the center of his own universe and
all of that is is is is terrifying and
an ignorant in the extreme I mean one of
when I wrote about science and and the
candidates this year this year one of
the statements that Trump made that just
to me epitomizes the level of ignorance
of the man because first of all a lot of
what he says is just meant he doesn't
care whether it's true or not he thinks
it'll play well or not that I can
understand that's power when you say you
know why are we worried about the ozone
why can't I have you know aerosols in my
hairspray because I only use my
hairspray indoors so it can affect can
affect the atmosphere that one real
young really said that now that's the
kind of thing you say oh my goodness
gracious so anyway yeah that that was
tough so okay so we've got your feelings
on Trump I think I think they're clear
right yeah well I have I've been tried
to moderate them too
less you know the pied just wrote a
piece in The New Yorker today on the
nuclear threat and and to be more
serious
his misunderstanding of the fact that
nuclear weapons are not meant to be used
and in fact as I pointed out it
demonstrates a lot of our of the
illogical nature of our nuclear policy
but when he says if you you know if we
build them why can't we use them that
anyone who's thought about it realizes
you can't you can't use them in any
strategic way and yeah and so it's and
if he wants to encourage other countries
to build them he misunderstands the
whole point of proliferation and those
things are serious they're not you know
we can't laugh over that stuff yeah so I
really tried I think most of you know
why she showed I really tried to be fair
to him and and and whatever yeah so when
he's talked about the nuclear stuff and
I'll say something like you know Japan
should have nukes so that they could
demand them yes potentially from China
it seems to me that there's some grain
of truth in the in the concept of that
that that we shouldn't have to feel like
we have to do defend Japan well but
you're saying it really throws off every
sort of precept of how all these nations
have well it patrols off the precept of
really what we should be trying to do
with nuclear weapons which we isn't
talked up enough today which is we want
to reduce the number of nuclear weapons
the world because there's really no good
use for the right eye and we we built up
this incredible stash of nuclear weapons
because of the Cold War and we had this
a policy of mutually assured destruction
so we had to have enough to ensure the
total annihilation of the Soviet Union
when they were the Soviet Union and
that's okay but we then even at the time
of Nixon we signed a non-proliferation
treaty most people think the
non-proliferation treaty and this is
this is it's so typical of the u.s. yeah
is designed to say no one should have
nuclear weapons but us and that's not
what it's about
yeah it's trying to say we don't want to
nuclear weapons to spread but the other
thing that the nuclear nations agreed to
in the non-proliferation treaty was to
disarm and so we have an obligation we
are violating the non-proliferation
treaty today in this country as much as
North Korea maybe by
to get nuclear weapons or getting nuke
weapons or on a which happily they've
been stopped from getting them for the
moment yeah because we are not making an
open effort at its arm and Obama who
whose heart was certainly the right
place he said you know we we should the
world should should get rid of nuclear
weapons and initially the the his
administration actually did an intern
agreement with the Soviet Union with the
Russia to reduce the number of arms but
we still have way too many we still have
a thousand nuclear weapons on
hair-trigger alert which means they can
be launched instantaneously if there's a
warning of an attack whether the warning
is real or not the president only has a
few minutes to decide that is not
necessary in the modern world and also
unfortunately and I'm happy to see that
that Hillary Clinton seems to be against
it
we are barking on a one trillion dollar
modernization of the nuclear weapons
fleet which is only reasonable if we
plan to keep our nuclear weapons level
at what it is if we say no you know
eventually we want to reduce them we
don't have to spend that much money
trying to maintain the Arsenal we now
have and so it's interesting to me to
see that the nuclear issue which over
time has been has raised and lowered in
importance the public doesn't seem to
think about it but it is still the major
threat the major existential threat to
civilization and and we as a country are
not doing enough and it is true at the
same time we're probably going to this
more than you wanted no no it's true
that that Russia is getting more
worrisome than they were for that the
saber-rattling the arguments about
nuclear weapons are much worse now under
Putin in the last few years and they
were so there's some concerns in that
regard but but we could you take
unilateral steps which would lead us in
the right direction right so even if
Russia was 10 times worse than you might
yeah it is if we add half of our
stockpile it would still be more than
enough to destroy we had an end of our
so if we had a tenth of our stockpile we
could still not only annihilate the
Soviet Union but essentially create
enough mess to destroy the world right
and it we we need to we need to realize
that fact and and and realize that we
can as I say unilateral actions are
often responded
to for example another area where we
spend money that we it's a wet wait
wasted time for the most part is missile
defense when one of the things I love is
that with George Bush claimed that they
were gonna have a missile defense system
ready in 2004 he was during the election
and and of course turned out that most
fifty percent of the American public
thought we already had one yeah and as
they are at the time what they should
say is we already have one there we go
because because they're just as
effective as this system that doesn't
work but it doesn't cost a hundred
billion dollars so it's a lot less
expensive and and it it serves the same
effect so how much of this though is
just that a huge percentage of our
economy is tied into the military it is
but you know the but what you're hearing
in the presidential election is we're
not spending enough and that's what's
scary what we need to do is spend
rationally people say that for a long
time you know we spend almost a trillion
dollars on defense every year and the
question is we have to look and say what
are we need look it's not as if we can
disarm as a nation completely in all
ways the world is a dangerous place but
the question is do we need to spend that
kind of money and the answer I think for
many people is we could spend less more
effectively do you think there is any
situation where ethically we could use
nukes I mean if let's say because I
don't think it's going to be through a
nation state but let's say they you know
somebody got a dirty bomb in here and
blew up Times Square so the question is
what do you I think the answer generally
is no nuclear weapons right now are
useful for deterrence to stop other
people from doing things but it is you
hit an interesting point that that when
might you use them and the cont what
many people may not realize is that the
country has no most people think the US
has in no first use policy namely we
would never be the first ones using we
don't write that because we said well
what if not someone uses nuclear weapons
but what if someone launches biological
weapons you know shouldn't we a lot be
allowed to nuke them or what if someone
nukes South Korea should we allowed to
nuke response and so these are questions
that you can debate but on the whole the
question is what what do you gain versus
conventional forces and we know other
than act of anger right what act has
already been done
here what yeah yeah so the question is
what you the idea should be to stop that
in the future uh
not and and inevitably the problem is
that under many scenarios once you start
using nuclear weapons the it proliferate
sand and what's been pointed out by a
bunch of physicists even about ten years
ago you may remember nuclear winter with
Carl Sagan and that there was that was
sort of discredited a little bit but in
fact even at a limited nuclear war say
between India and Pakistan of fifty or
hundred weapons which may sound like a
lot but it's the kind of thing you might
expect in a nuclear war would would
raise enough basically dust in the
atmosphere
to for a decade effect agriculture
ultimately perhaps killing a billion
people through starvation so there's no
such thing as a limited nuclear war and
it and everyone including the right wing
guys like George Shultz and Henry
Kissinger came up a bunch years ago and
said we need to basically work towards a
nuclear free world because as long as we
have nuclear weapons we're all at risk
so how do you untie that then from the
legitimate parts of deterrent if your
argument is that deterrence is an
important piece of a strategy because
might be by having deterrence you don't
necessarily have to fight a ground war
how do you untie those well for example
well how many we can ask right now how
many nuclear weapons you need to deter a
a an aggressor and it says you certainly
don't need we the United States of 5,000
so view the Russia Russia excuse me I
grew up in the Soviet Union forgetting
what your yeah yeah I know I know
exactly the Russia has Russia has
another five thousand that's you know we
don't need five thousand weapons to
deter you know hundred nuclear weapons
would be more than enough to destroy
basically any country and and
dramatically affect the world so maybe
we can immediately go down 100 weapons
nobody a difference then ultimately for
someone that's hearing you and saying
well if we happen but we're not using
what's the difference whether we have
5000 well it's it to maintain a fleet of
5000 weapons including the
infrastructure requires an incredible
amount of money got it so that alone in
practice one trillion dollar
modernization gives you an example of
the infrastructure costs so their
economic costs as well as security costs
and if we decided rationally you know
what it's better to
you know it's like if you have ten cars
it cost you a lot more money to maintain
them than if you have one it's not just
the cost of the cars yeah so as a
theoretical physicist when you talk
about all of this stuff you you have an
insight into how things actually work
that the average person doesn't have do
you worry that you'll ever stumble upon
something or you know somehow
accidentally or maybe intentionally you
find something and then realize how it
could be turned into something horrific
I mean that's like the big epochal oh I
see no happily what I I'm always pleased
to say that what I work on has no
practical significance whatsoever I
heard you say that reality but but I've
read about the origins in history of the
universe and and and you know you can
never of course the great thing about
science is you never know what's going
to be discovered or what the implication
so that I guess what if you had to pick
one area that had less direct practical
significance it'd be hard to find one
that more than mine which worries where
I try and understand how the universe
began and how it's going to and these
these questions are incredibly important
for us culturally but but the kind of
new physics that we try and develop and
understand affects the universe on
scales that really are divorced from
human scales directly obviously they
they relate to what the reason you know
how we got here my new book which I will
plug called the greatest story ever told
so far
yeah the subtitles now March 27 March
2017 is and it's but the subtitle called
why are we here yeah and and ultimately
we want to understand those questions
and unfortunately religion tries to
preserve those questions I want to point
out how science address them so they're
fundamental sort of cultural questions
but but I like to say although it's
pretentious because I don't want to meet
comparison but my work is or the work by
people like me is as useful as a Mozart
symphony I mean it's it's best at its
best it could be as useful as a Mozart
symphony it enhances the cultural
experience of being human
so I'm happily I'm not as worried about
that but on the other hand what we need
to do is is there's an old expression I
think from Pasteur but it could be from
later on I never I've tried to track it
down but fortune favors the prepared
mind and what we need to do or think
about
what the possibilities are so we're
prepared to act and we can't be prepared
to act if we put our heads in the sand
so we can say oh we should never you
know uh do genetic engineering but it's
happening we so we can talk about
artificial intelligence and say we need
to we need to stop that but it's not
going to be stopped what we need to do
or think about the possibilities and
that's one of the reasons why the
origins project that run it is you is so
for me so exciting because we try to
bring scientists together to look at for
fferent questions but then we have
public events where three thousand
people attend and listen and the point
is to and then you know you can't have a
good democracy without an informed
population and and so to try and raise
these questions and get people to think
about the possibilities are will allow
us to be better prepared for unn for
suprising possibilities in the future
because we don't know where the future
lies I often say and I said it on a film
recently that I'm not if someone tells
you they're a futurist in my mind that's
when you stop listening because I try
not to make predictions about anything
other than like 2 trillion years in the
future right that's a what do you call
that as a super future well yeah there
is first of all no one will be around to
test it and it's much easier but but but
we don't discoveries are called
discoveries because they're surprises
but we can try and at least anticipate
the set of possibilities so we'll be a
little less surprised and all of us can
do that and that's why you know you say
I'm a scientist and I have access it's
true I have access to some information
people don't normally have access to but
the process of science we can all be at
least have a perspective of what's
happening and that's why it's important
that's why I spend time in in the my
with my public hat trying to trying to
explain and explore science for the
public not just because it's interesting
and exciting and it is it's fun and
people are fascinated by it but because
hopefully it'll be useful when people
try and confront the challenges of the
21st century all right so I want to
spend the rest of this talking about
your actual work ok origins and stuff
like that but my last question on this
part I don't have no agenda but I know
you don't you made it very clear which I
love that so but my last part goes to
your public happy because clearly you're
willing to talk about politics you're
willing to you know speak about things
freely and
you emailed me I have no no agenda again
do you ever fear that that will have a
professional cost just by saying things
why don't ya it does all the time but I
suppose someone said no I fear about
that I would have stopped a long time
ago I guess
look I think there's not day goes by
they don't realize I'm fortunate in a
way that people for one reason or
another want to listen to me or at least
I have a public profile and therefore I
have a responsibility it seems to me to
use that profile responsibly and that
means of course to try and and and and
and popularize science in a way but also
to try and do what I can to to have an
impact so in some sense you know it goes
hand in hand with what I said to you
about my work my work has no practical
significance whatsoever but I'm but as a
human being I'm very political or I'm
very interested in what's going on and
therefore in some sense maybe I make up
for the fact that my work has no
usefulness by taking advantage of my
public profile to try and and do useful
things and one of the useful things can
try and be least to provoke people to
think about these things and so that's
what I do alright so now let's let's get
into the work part of it part that
apparently has no meaning or no it has
lots of meaning but no significance I
know it has significance in a global
sense in a cosmic sense in a in a in a
in a in a existential sense yeah but it
doesn't it won't cause a better toaster
will be built and you know that's one of
the problems with science is that it has
practical utility it's obviously on a
problem because we couldn't be doing
this show we wouldn't people wouldn't
live as long as they live our modern
society is based on the result science
but because science produces technology
to change our lives people suddenly
think that unless it's related to
technology it's not interesting
whereas I say art doesn't produce
anything practical so people don't
expect there could say you know what
that Picasso painting hasn't produced
something that makes me live longer
right and but and so because science has
that practical side people forget the
cultural side that they the knowledge
side and that's to me as important as
anything what I've I've quoted in a
number of times and but I'll quote it
again here
one of my favorite statements from a guy
named Robert Wilson who was the director
of the first director of the Fermi
National Accelerator Laboratory which is
a particle accelerator near Chicago
which accelerates particles to look at
fundamental structure matter it was the
largest such machine in the world until
the Large Hadron Collider was built in
in Geneva but when it was being built he
was called by Congress to testify and he
was asked will it aid in the defense of
the nation and he have a beautiful
statement but the end of it was
basically no it won't help aid in the
defense the nation it'll just help keep
the nation worth defending ah that's me
that actually is really beautiful I
think it is that's why I quote them so
that's sort of it it's a problem of
funding things in a way because if you
fund something people want results and
what you're saying is basically the
whole playground of science isn't tied
into that and well so it's a real
problem now in government funding and in
the public people seem to want to fund
things based in fact I wrote another
piece on the House Science Committee
which basically wanted to require and
did to some extent scientists and their
grant applications to justify why what
they're doing is in the national
interest and the net and what I think
necessarily anything to do with science
well the point is that seems to me the
natural the national interest is in
increasing our knowledge yeah and and
it's not in and so if you if you require
things directly to have a practical
application then you're going to miss
almost everything you it's already been
well documented that probably fifty
percent of the current gross national
product of this country is based on
fundamental curiosity driven research
that that was done a generation ago
accidents you know discovery of
penicillin they weren't looking for
antibiotics so even the development of
transistor wasn't if people said we
won't need to make better computers back
at the time when they were using wheels
and other things and they would have
missed the use of transistors so all of
the things that have changed our lives
even the World Wide Web which was
developed at Geneva the home of the
Large Hadron Collider to help scientists
communicate in large experiments when
you have ten thousand scientists around
the world it was important for them to
be able to exchange results without
worrying about where the results were
and being able to communicate that's
what developed the world wide web and of
course that's changed the world so
you need to support fundamental
curiosity-driven research if you stop
doing that then not only do we suffer as
a species but not our learning going not
increasing but all ultimately the
spin-offs that are going to change our
lives are not going to occur yeah
so you mentioned Carl Sagan before and
my my scientific awakening was a little
slow I hate to admit it I was always
into sci-fi when I was growing up there
are Wars and all that stuff but my real
scientific awakening I saw the movie
contact and I had eaten pot brownies
before I thought I was going to see I
think Air Force one but it was sold out
so I just went into contract had no idea
what it was about didn't really know
much about Carl Sagan but you know the
opening panoramic Jambres and my mind on
pop Roundy's I mean even it exploded I
since have read every Carl Sagan book
and all that kind of what was that
moment for you I suspect it was a lot
younger than it was it was I was a
little younger a lot earlier got older
but um actually you know well I'm not
sure there was an epiphany in that way
but there was a but the first thing I
can remember was when I was in grade six
reading a book about Galileo and and and
and it seemed romantic and remarkable to
me the fact that he was the first one to
look up at them and moons of Jupiter and
it changed everything and and also the
courage he had at art or lack thereof at
times to confront conventional wisdom
that seemed to me to be a romantic
adventure that captured my imagination
and that's probably one of the reasons
why I write books is because it was
books about him and then books by people
like Isaac Asimov well before Carl Sagan
but uh and George gamma and Albert
Einstein and then Richard Richard
Feynman books by people like that got me
excited as a young person about the
romantic adventure to be the to be the
first to understand something new about
the world and and so I return the favor
and I'm old enough now that it's for me
very satisfying although a little
depressing to think how old and when
what I mean scientists now say you know
I read the physics of Star Trek and
that's what turned me in to be with
scientists so but it was those popular
books and I and that's why although it
takes time out of
out of my research directly it I'm not
sure which is more useful in the long
run and besides I don't have control I
have to do what I have to do when
writing is one of them but but it's very
satisfying to be able to connect because
the importance of a university or of the
research enterprise is twofold and
that's one of the reasons why my origins
project is twofold University Research
University should be based on the
creation of knowledge but if you don't
disseminate the knowledge it's impotent
so it has to be - to fold and and so I
like to be involved in both for some
reason yeah so the origins project
you're trying to figure out the origins
of humans and the universe and we're
looking at the origins of everything
it's riggs it's a wonderful playground
because we look at everything from the
origins of universe to the origins of
life to the origins of violence and and
and where we're having we're having and
the origins of the future we're having a
workshop in in February and the unnie I
and its challenges so if you think about
it forefront questions there's a
relationship always between the future
in the past and forefront questions are
always bate about the origin what's the
origin of disease what's the origin of
intelligence and so as a curious person
I can go well beyond just my area of
physics which tends to be more related
the origin in the universe when which
has got me into it - all these other
questions I'm like a kid in a candy shop
I get to meet and work with the most
interesting people in the world and
learn a lot about a lot of things so
it's just it's really Self Indulgence
which is most of my life is based on but
it's bringing a lot of good - a lot of
people say well me hey self-indulgence
and and individuality is good yeah well
you know that's the other thing I guess
I want to say is that most people become
scientists not because they want to save
the world it's because they like doing
it it's fun and and there's nothing and
and that's fine I I tell kids that's
when they talk ask me what they should
do I say do what you enjoy because if
you don't enjoy you're not going to do
well anyway yeah but I do science you
know it's great if it has an impact in
one way or another but I do it because I
enjoy it and in that and I and I am
unabashed about that yeah so I'm very
proud that on this show I which I try to
bring on people of all kinds of beliefs
and political persuasions and all that
stuff
I get tons of email from religious
people even though they know that I'm
not a believer that's tough
so we don't have to dive too much into
the atheism thing but can you how about
you give me the best cell job in like
three minutes on the big bang like just
something that someone that that is a
believer of religion could say well
maybe there's something here maybe
there's some well I the point is that
it's it's it's it's sad that I have to
do that because did I leave too much of
that question maybe I should untangle
them no no but I mean one makes it sound
like the Big Bang is on a different
footing than the fact that the earth is
round it's not the Big Bang happened the
same with evolution it's not you know
people get hung up in the word theory
well you know if someone just wrote me
and said well you know it's a theory and
I said well gravity is a theory too so
if you don't believe it walk out the
tent for our window it's but the point
is a theory in science means it's been
tested theories are very high level in
science it means it's satisfied the test
experiment over and over and over again
and the fact that the the universe began
it that the universe was once smaller
than it is today and smaller and smaller
and smaller and was once contained in a
microscopic region 13.8 billion years
ago that expanded dramatically is is is
a fact and it and everything we see we
recognize about the universe is only
understandable in that context there are
lots of independent ways to measure the
age of the universe and we come up with
13.8 billion years we measure the fact
the universe is expanding working
backwards it was once smaller than it is
and if we extrapolate back and say what
happened when a smaller we make
predictions about things that we hadn't
seen before people say evolution or the
Big Bang are historical science because
no one was around they often write me no
one was around to know so how do you
know and I say well the point is all
science is historical because all
science is based on explaining some
observations are done but then making
predictions of things that haven't been
done and both evolution and the Big Bang
make predictions about things that
weren't seen before if if the Big Bang
happened we were predicted it was
predicted although a lot of Sciences
didn't know about it until after the
fact that there should be a universal
background of radiation coming at us
that was once three
thousand degrees in temperature that's
now three degrees that's been measured
with exquisite prediction yeah our quiz
it precision sorry
and also we predict that 25% of the
universe should be helium and almost 75%
of the other should be hydrogen and one
part in 10 billion the universe should
be lithium we go out and measure that 10
orders of magnitude so we make tons of
predictions of things that's what
science is not just a story like
religion it makes predictions and if
those predictions don't agree with
observations they're wrong so so we
throw the up we throw it out like
yesterday's newspaper so the story that
word historical science which a lot of
fundamentalist use to try and discredit
evolution the Big Bang is nonsense
because they're not historical any more
than anything else they make predictions
about observations that are gonna be
made in the future and every observation
we made about the universe is consistent
only with that picture and inconsistent
with any other idea yeah so you would
say the evidence that we have for the
Big Bang is as much evidence as we have
the dinosaurs existed right it's just a
different that we have no moral moreover
we have evidence that dinosaurs didn't
exist when humans exist no matter what
they show in that silicon's wrong as
ever it's easy to say oh yeah I've been
there I would they're there the day it
opened I have you feel about that it was
a remarkable experience I was there the
day open I I flew to to Cincinnati and
then into Kentucky on the other side
where was that morning to lead to be the
keynote speaker in a protest that
morning and then at because it is it's
it's that willingness that the SATA it's
it's child abuse the idea is okay they
believe something and and therefore they
don't want kids to know what really
happened they don't want kids to know
that evolution happened because somehow
it might reduce their faith in God and
so the idea that you want your kids to
not know how the universe works because
for fear that they lose our faith is no
different than the Taliban when they
won't teach the kids anything but but
memorizing the Quran and and and so it's
it's worse than ignorance it's that it's
it's child abuse so I would so I went
there and protested and then I actually
I had credentials I was a commentator
for NPR and I went up to right
afterwards and they recognized me and
they said oh professor Krauss you
credentials didn't arrived you can't go
in so I said that's okay I happen to
have a crew from PBS and and BBC that
are following me right now do you mind
if they film me not being allowed in the
museum and then I got a guided tour by
at the time the vice-president Museum
and it was it was it was shocking it's
amazing they do a bait-and-switch it was
amazing and they start out quite upfront
in the saying reason and faith they
braid in the front door a reason to
faith why should and they point out that
the two are different and then they and
they and then in the front are you
should believe in reason you should
believe in faith and then and then they
halfway through the museum they make it
seem like a Natural History Museum so
they do this bait-and-switch and but but
it's hysterical because they have a
Garden of Eden with Adam and Eve both
politically correct Adam is and graphs
up to here and Eve has hair down to
there but they have dinosaurs you know
in the Garden of Eden of course and they
trying to source Rex you know is there
it's got sharp teeth why everything was
a vegetarian in the Garden of Eden you
may not have realized that but but if
you go to the museum will discover that
you're not and it's so they could open
pineapples so they could eat open that's
why the Tyrannosaurus Rex had sharp
teeth Wow you know I knew I was going to
learn something there you go with you
here today I'm glad that that will end
up being it I really will have a couple
minutes left I'm curious do you find
that you have colleagues that believe in
everything that you just said there or
you know everything we've talked about
the the the ideas of everything you said
but at the same time are there some
people that do take the leap of faith oh
sure then and then believe in things
that aren't on same time yeah first by
the way we should say as scientists we
should never use the word believe I know
no I mean I mean as it's just I fall in
that trap to believing is not part of
science it's is it likely or unlikely
and that's the question yeah but of
course they're religious scientists but
as I like to say there are scientists or
Republicans I mean the scientists
believe it or not are human beings and
human beings are in some sense hardwired
to believe two mutually inconsistent
things at the same time I often say that
we all have to believe ten impossible
things before breakfast just to get up
in the morning you have to believe you
like your job or your spouse or whatever
yet we all invent stories to go by and
so there are scientists religious as
long as they don't let that religious
faith to interfere with their work it
doesn't matter and and the good
scientists so that way but
but but the making the claim that their
scientists are religious does not mean
that they're compatible neither does
making the claim that science derives
from religion because it does I mean but
you know in the history of West at least
all of universities were once religious
institutions because as I like to say in
the 17th century the church was the
National Science Foundation was the only
play if you wanted to get money yeah
then that was the place to get it if you
wanted to support your idea so it's not
too surprising that science grew out of
religion but as I also like to say and
again to plug said and to say in the new
book yeah that you know children often
move away from their parents okay and so
so talking about the background does not
mean that that science and religion are
compatible because they're not they're
not compatible in the sense of being
compatible with the specific doctrines
or the world's great religions science
isn't incompatible with the vague notion
that there may be purpose to the
universe there's no evidence of it
whatsoever right and there's no need for
a God as I showed in my last book
there's no need for even supernatural
stuff to create a whole universe but
science can't disprove the notion of
some vague deity okay but what I can say
is you know the earth didn't stop when
someone blew a trumpet and there wasn't
a virgin birth and all of those things
that's incompatible with what we know
about the universe
yeah all right we have two minutes left
what is one thing that people aren't
thinking about that you're a physicist
theoretical physicist you're thinking of
something on a day to day basis that the
average person is not thinking about
give me something that was lots of
things that we should be thinking about
that we're not well I don't know what we
should but something something fun is
that the is the future of the universes
is different than we might believe it
might be in fact we we may be living at
a very special time in the history of
the universe and and when it turns out
that what we've just discovered about
the Higgs boson tells us that everything
we see in the universe may be unstable
that that matter as we know it could not
immediately so don't go ahead and sell
your stocks or anything yeah but that
enough in the far future that not only
we know the rest the universal disappear
because it's already expanding away
from us faster than the speed of light
at least it's receding from us faster
than the speed of light so that and and
so the longer we wait the less will
we'll be able to see of the universe but
it turns out that like an icicle on a
window or ice crystal on a window in a
summer morning will eventually melt the
Higgs field that is allowing everything
we now see to exist could eventually
melt in a different kind of way and if
it does then matter as we know it will
disappear so we should enjoy our brief
moment in the Sun yeah so it's not going
to happen tomorrow no way if we're right
we're on the hairy edge of it it may
never happen and we what we're trying to
discover at the Large Hadron Collider is
will it happen or or might it happen but
even if it was we know it's not going to
happen for a heck of a long time yeah so
there's time to try and make sure we
keep the present world working which
means we have to vote responsibly and
ask yourself what when you hear
something on TV as the former publisher
of the New York Times said and I use my
mantra I like to keep an open mind but
not so open that my brains fall out all
right well that's a perfect ending I
hope you'll come back in March when you
do a proper press tour okay that'll be
fun this in that I can promote more
building you again yeah yeah it's true
it's good and it sometimes works
it's occasionally it works all right
well for more on Lawrence's work on
there is a ton of it he's written a
gajillion books I will put the link down
to to the new book right below check out
Kraus faculty dot asu.edu
you
[Music]